yesterday I got in trouble with the
kalila because um I don't even guys know
this I want to talk about my weekend
first of all I'm just gonna tell you
what I went through this weekend okay
well it started last week last week I
don't know if you know this but um the
new DLC came out for destiny and it's
called the rise of iron and as you know
I'm addicted to the game and you have to
work really hard to catch up with
everyone else you can't do there's this
thing called the nightfall right um
Vanguard mission you can't do it if
you're not a 360 light level okay so you
have to do you have to at least get to
there I'm not there I'm at 3:51 so what
needed to happen was as soon as the DLC
dropped I should just been playing
because coke my friend coke Eric Hauck
from the UFC if I he played to a 24
hours straight with his friend holy [ __ ]
that's ways out of 3 7 anyway but then I
did oddball this weekend how many
festive it's a comedy festival in Texas
and I just want to tell people about my
experience with it ok oddball is one of
those things that I secretly always
wanted to do because all the cool kids
were doing it Chappelle Amy Schumer um
all of them Aziz Oz eyes as awesome as
ours are oh okay
and I have never been asked I've never
even thought I could ever go because I
always feel like I'm not relevant or I'm
just out of the loop and they asked me
this year to only do three okay and I
want to tell people Live Nation and
people at Funny or Die thank you so much
for the experience and I really enjoyed
myself I did it with Dane all right who
was hot and cold with me all weekend
your beef well here's what happened this
is what happened I show up to the
airport Thursday morning to go to
Houston and when I go on the road
everybody and it's not that I can't
afford it I fly coach I always do
I tried to add when MADtv got cancelled
to do first class because I thought I
was a star but I'm not so I just went
you know what I'm gonna do coach for the
rest of my life
it's fine my ego can take it I show up
and Tom Segura Dane Cook [ __ ] and
Sebastian Maniscalco all had first class
you had the past so they got on first
and then I started sweating and then I
kind of went right so they call I'm like
what Zone number 15 I mean I'm the last
guy right
I shall I come on right I'm now worried
to things when you're coach and you're
zone number 15 you don't even know if
your shit's gonna be able to get on the
plane you have to you know sometimes all
the open you know the overhead
compartments are filled filled and you
have to check your bag in so that's my
number one fear but also along that is
walking by the 3 so I walk on and
they're sitting there and immediately
all three of them start laughing like
little kids in my face yummy I mean and
when you're coming on a flight like that
you're not zipping past [ __ ]
first-class standing you're standing
because there's always two old people
you know I mean they take some [ __ ]
20 minutes get the [ __ ] thing on the
thing all right so I'm scanning there
right and then gang goes big fan man and
then they started laughing again right
and it was just I'm blushing sweating
and crying at the same time it's really
sad then I can finally get past them and
in my head I'm like it is a crime what
happened it doesn't end through the
whole flight these [ __ ] they go keep
going back there god damn it and
throwing blankets at me first-class
pillows right right had one time one of
what Stewart goes they just wanted to
say hi from the first class you know all
three all three of them right it was
human
to say the least we do the gig right
number one I don't know if anyone's a
stand up listening to me but doing an
outside event in front of thousands of
people is very difficult okay
but I did it and the whole weekend was
great I got to know Tom Segura really
well and let me say my [ __ ] opinion
about Tom Segura he is a 10 and I'm
about to cry
he's a good dude his special is my
favorite of the year last year he's a
good dude another [ __ ] I'm gonna tell
you another person right vali Wang no
Ali walk le Wang yeah I'm about to cry
[ __ ] good girl men you guys go way
back - we go way back you know but see
how much she has grown is really just an
amazing thing to see and I love Asian
company as you know that fan number one
one of my faves was he there no okay
well aren't you the only comic that
didn't have a car to pick you up to it
from the airport yeah yeah
what so I show up and I have to take a
now a cab a yellow cab and everyone has
limo she's is right and this is why I
love Tom I'm outside and he could shoot
it because you know first class they
leave the flight I'm the last receipt so
as soon as I get off the flight they're
gone
there's nobody which I wanted yeah so
I'm slowly getting through I go outside
Tom Segura waited for me because I don't
think you have a ride do you no no
that's what I heard
and I said no yeah and he goes I'll give
you a ride and he gave me a ride and
then he did that a couple times man and
then um and then after Austin Saturday
night they invited me to dinner it was
me I alley Tom Segura and uh an agent
and Jermaine Fowler I love him too you
know Jimmy Fowler yes
yeah yeah he's a skinny little he's not
that skinny he's very handsome he's very
handsome
that guy yeah yeah yeah he's young he
just got in a shower or was but he him
and I shared a room or our dressing room
was just me and oh yeah
say that I want to say that the whole
thing was great and I just anyone
listening right now if you're if you
like Tom Segura like him or I also I did
shows with also Eliza love her okay
Dana you know why do you say hot and
cold with him just cuz some days he
wouldn't talk to it's fine you know me
and Sebastian I mean he I went to his
wedding
yeah one of the best comics in the
country and um but you know I came home
and I um needed to catch up on the
destiny because everyone did I played
the whole time I was gone and now I'm
behind and I played yesterday but I got
in trouble why did you get in trouble
kalila um let's see
he comes through the door drops his
suitcase get the haagen-dazs yeah three
minutes turns our home into an absolute
just like crime scene yeah the watches
the dog you know piss in front of him on
the floor yeah and then proceeds to
scream for ten hours straight at the TV
I mean tell me what what type of person
I would have to be to not at least be to
be even you know annoyed and I didn't
that I was trying to communicate to him
[Music]